vous ne pouvez pas les rater sur le
parvis de la cathédrale d'orléans se
sont invités trois fauteuils en hommage
à son concepteur l'architecte claude
parent décédé en 2005 et à l'occasion de
la biennale je voulais les sortir pour
les activer comme un vrai mobilier
urbain et puis surtout pour utiliser ici
le parvis de la cathédrale
exactement comme le veut le dessin de ce
parti qui fonctionne comme une scène de
théâtre
une oeuvre qui répond à une scène de
théâtre dont et si l'on s'assoit dans
les fauteuils
on découvre alors une rue jeanne-d'arc
aux allures espagnol une enfilade de
drapeaux sur lesquels sont dessinés les
projets de tous les architectes
architecture c'est pas que le bâtiment
acheté curci tout un ensemble de choses
et les sens de l' architecture c'est le
dessin de l'architecte
j'ai toujours dit que les bâtiments
construits sont des copies des originaux
qui sont les dessins faut jamais oublier
l'original c'est le dessin le bâtiment
réalisé c'est une copie et là vous avez
des idées d'architectes ils sont exposés
autres lieux dans la ville ou la
biennale a pris ses quartiers
rendez-vous à l'intérieur cette fois la
collégiale saint-pierre le plus ailier
ce matin-là à j moins 11 on était alors
en pleine phase de montage
cet élément là arrivent à cette hauteur
on n'est pas à tromper ses 50 sur le
dessin au milieu de la collégiale un
drôle d'objet signe harry styles omt
onas sorte d'imaginaire d'un appartement
flottant qui réduit l'habitat au strict
minimum
il part d'un constat très simple que
nous n'habitons plus nulle part ce que
nous sommes continuellement connecter au
reste du monde il qu'on fait nos lieux
qui nous abrite ne nous sert que pour
repartir après virtuellement
cette année l'invité d'honneur et
patrick bouchain celui à qui l'on doit
le formidable circuit une gare ou
aubervilliers offre au frac centre
toutes ses oeuvres une rétrospective est
un travail immense au service de
l'humain architecture sais c'est pas un
art c'est une nécessité
les hommes ne peuvent pas ne pas
construire pour se protéger
c'est comme le langage c on peut aussi
on ne parlait pas très chaud ici on ne
construit pas c'est faux parce que l'
architecture fait toujours débat
la biennale d'orléans première édition
vous attend quatre coins de la ville
jusqu'au 1er avril